[Music]  [Applause]  tonight JLo is back in New York with her  man a rod she plans to rehearse every  day until Monday's VMA performance if J  Lo's routine mirrors past Vanguard  recipients like pink Britney or Beyonce  TV it will last around 15 minutes and  contain a medley of her biggest hits on  Instagram JLo admitted to feeling  nostalgic while posting clips of her  classic music videos I always wanted to  be in show business I guess from that  early age et was on set of her first  video 1999 if you had my love  [Music]  the 29 year old was already a film star  thanks to her breakout role in Selena  [Music]  but she hadn't yet released her debut  album on the six I take both careers  very seriously  hopefully you know the music do you know  do well and I'll be able to continue  doing that as well as the movies you  know you know I'm just gonna keep  working hard  [Music]